did you know you had this performance in
you did you know that as an actor you
had this I knew it wasn't asked of me I
knew it was material I hadn't seen
before and I just knew the basics of it
when I went to meet Darren he wasn't
certain how he was going to make this
movie because it would require the actor
to clearly wear extensive prosthetic
makeup yeah to create Charlie's body and
did that help or hinder help absolutely
because it was designed with the rules
that it would obey gravity in physics
and it was it was appropriately heavy
and that really made the experience of
playing the part I think really a lot
closer to what it would be like to live
in a body of a man that size for me
personally because when it came off I
could still feel an undulation you know
when you get the feeling when you step
off a boat onto a dock yeah yeah you're
kind of in vertical yeah I think what
that was is just showing me that
it's still with me and and it also let
me know that
to be a person of that size you really
have to be very strong physically just
depend emotionally yeah and I grew to
appreciate that by having played this
part and uh you're one of those actors
you've been working constantly and yet
this is being described as your
Renaissance because people like words
like that does it feel they have I
didn't make this [__] up
look we just work here okay
does it feel like a Renaissance to you
every time I hear that I want to look at
the ceiling
oh look here's Rick O'Connell oh look
there's George of the Jungle
before shortening
I'm just you can call me whatever you
want just as long as you're calling me
okay
[Applause]
[Music]